urubus pessoal visa mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer o arco usando
cinco pontes de picolé 4 elástico
escritório fio e cola é qual é opcional
mas o cão saiu o primeiro quarto em um
time com mais ou menos esta aparência
sobrepõe à outra parte e faça um outro
igual
seria marcante centro político oponham
cola dos dois lados do da linha
além desta maneira os pontinhos
propósito destes conteúdos é pagar um
crescimento do pleito baixo com este
lema que estou claro agora portanto
estar bem para ficar bem sobre o posto
baixo
agora vamos introduzir o povo desta
maneira e prendê lo com elástico
vou dar voltas até que eu não fico mais
em fazer o mesmo por outro lado é
promover por dois de cada lado mas
alguns lances de emoção muito forte
então não é preciso basta um de cada
lado
depois porém um fio no ar vocês podem
pôr um peeling cola para ficar mais
resistente porque o que aconteceu e por
algumas vezes e phil se desprendia o
ponto alto desta feita o arco e uma
flecha eu comprei esta são muito baratas
ganham já com um arco de plástico pois
foi só estarão também e só seria o
soffin hospedam estados vocês gostaram
mesmo e chegou a sonhar você ouvir e se
inscreva no canal isto ajuda bastante a
divulgação ea evolução do meu trabalho
obrigado pelo braço até a próxima que é